er hat mehrere sachen gesagt die arafat
schlimmer sein können
steuerrechtlich als die die ja vor dem
strafgericht zu erwarten hat bushido hat
zwei einmal ein zahlenbeispiel gegeben
von 100.000 euro musste er alleine circa
50.000 euro versteuern 30.000 bekam
arafat so hat er es gesagt und 20.000
blieben dann für bushido selbst sollte
das zutreffen ist das natürlich ein
schlimmer vorwurf der
steuerhinterziehung und er sagt auch
dass er nach einem vorfall während eines
konzerts ein manager vertrag 2007 mit
arafat abou chaker abgeschlossen hat und
der manager vertrag als vertrag muss
dann auch die abgabenordnung und die
umsatzsteuer abfuhr von arafat auch
festlegen so in dem zusammenhang wird
immer wieder von der l capone falle
gesprochen erklären es das was ist das
was hat es damit auf sich
ja also auch al capone kriegte man
strafrechtlich nicht zu fassen
nur alleine über die steuerhinterziehung
§ 370 die abgabenordnung regelt die
steuerhinterziehung und die sagt wer
falsche unwahre oder nicht vollständige
angaben zu seinen einkünften abgibt
beginnt eine steuerhinterziehung
strafverschärfend ist dabei tue ich das
als mitglied einer bande sind also
mehrere daran beteiligt oder aber ist
ein steuerschaden von über 50.000 oder
100.000 pro jahr entstanden ist das
strafverschärfend
eine abschließende frage apotheker der
schere jetzt beziehungsweise erklären
die stehen ja nicht zum ersten mal vor
gericht die haben sich immer irgendwie
herausgefunden wie wahrscheinlich ist es
denn überhaupt dass es jetzt zu einer
verurteilung kommt und was droht eben
dann also strafrechtlich wird das ein
ganz langer prozess der wird sich über
viele jahre wenn nicht sogar zehn jahre
hinziehen
und dann muss man gucken wie
rechtskräftig da strafen ausgelobt
werden können überhaupt die einzige
strafe die wirklich jetzt im raum steht
die ihn wirklich treffen kann den arafat
abou chaker und alle möglichen männer
das sind die der steuerhinterziehung die
verjähren erst nach zehn jahren der
bundesgerichtshof hat ein urteil gefällt
bei einem steuerschaden von über einer
million im jahr bekommt eine
freiheitsstrafe von nicht unter zwei
jahren betracht dass straftaten oder
strafen über zwei jahren können dann
auch nicht mehr zur bewährung ausgesetzt
werden dann kommt er hinter gittern
wegen der steuer al capone falle